hey David is it transphobic to be
annoyed by people who declare their
gender pronouns unprovoked and when it
seems irrelevant this is a very loaded
question so I want to do this justice
and as is often the case with many of
the audience questions the question as
asked is not always the most important
question okay
so first I'll answer it as asked it
sounds like the person writing is
annoyed when someone says hey how are
you I'm Joe I use him in his pronouns or
whatever the case may be the person
writing says they find it annoying and
they want to know if that's transphobic
it's not I mean on principle it is not
transphobic to find that annoying
anymore than it would be annoying then
it would be trans than it would be you
know anti-religious to find it annoying
if someone announces their declares
their religion when you meet them or
whatever else in principle it is not
transphobic that being said if you
proactively don't care about addressing
people the way they want to be addressed
then you could argue that that starts to
sort of border on being transphobic in
some sense of the word but this really
comes down to what is it that's annoying
you about it are you annoyed that trans
people want to be treated like others
that's transphobic are you just annoyed
because you don't find it necessary as a
pretext to have a normal conversation
with anybody then that's not transphobic
whatsoever here's where I think this
starts to actually become an issue that
we should be talking about and I've
talked to a lot of college professors
about this my mom is a college professor
my sister goes to a school where one
year they started doing when you go
around the class on the first day
everybody announces their gender
pronouns then they stopped I think that
that is not a good idea I don't think
that it's a good idea in a college
classroom to say let's go around the
room everybody say hello tell me your
major and tell me your gender pronouns
or whatever and there's a few reasons
why I think that that's not the best
thing number one there are people who
could be in the class who are gender
non-binary or non-conforming who don't
necessarily know what the answer is to
that question and it could actually
really upset them and I've been told a
story by a professor who said you know I
I when we did this I had a student start
to cry because they were in the middle
of not necessarily a transition but a
period during which they were unsure
about what their sort of genuine gender
identity felt like and they became very
very upset now that's anecdotal but I do
think that at the at the bigger picture
level the right way that this should be
handled in school and this is the way
I've seen a lot of people do this
successfully is in advance of the class
something goes out and it says here's
how we're going to run the class here's
the attendance policy if you have either
a nickname or a gender pronoun that
would not be obvious to me from the way
your name is in the class registry let
me know in advance and I will make a
note of it period and it solves a lot of
these issues that can sometimes just
create more anxiety and put more
pressure around people than is necessary
and I've seen that done successfully by
a lot of colleagues and people that I
know and it seems to circumvent a lot of
the problems and it also seems to
circumvent what is this by some people
described just as an annoyance at
something that's not relevant not for
any transphobic reason but just because
they want to deal with people one on one
and they will they will of course treat
people the way they want to be treated
refer to them the way they want to be
treated but the idea of going around the
room and sort of identifying seems
unnecessary I want to hear from you
about it I have no problem having my
mind changed but from all of the college
professors I've spoken to the idea of
the declaration of gender pronouns as we
go around the room seems to me
unnecessary and sometimes sometimes
potentially problematic I know there
will be people who will write in and say
David that's transphobic I want to hear
thoughtful feedback on what I'm saying
not David you're transphobic
think I've made it abundantly clear on
this program that that is obviously not
the case we've got a great bonus show
for you today get instant access to it
two ways become a member at WWE
pakman.com become a patron at atleast
the $5 level at patreon.com slash david
pakman show tremendous bonus show today
and I look forward to speaking to you
then